que es un discurso que refleja mucho lo
que fue su campaña o sea en términos de
de que eso fue un voto a por la
democracia para tomar aspectos
importantes y esenciales para Brasil en
términos de de la de responder el tema
de la igualdad de la diversidad de
conocer esa diversidad y y al mismo
tiempo sinaloo de alguna manera pues no
hablo directamente los evangélicos pero
habló de la libertad deliciosa que ha
sido un tema que muchos de la campaña
contra Lula ha sido de que se cerraría
las iglesias y pues sabemos que 30% de
la población además de una población muy
católica también 30% de la población hoy
es es se considera evangélica Entonces
es importante también señalar en ese
sentido que que hay un diálogo
de respecto la libertad religiosa que
creo que era importante que lo la dejara
ahí muy muy muy en su discurso por
escrito casi firmado hay un tema ahí que
creo que que es hablando un poco lo que
acaba de decir Eduardo en términos de de
un dilema que creo que el gobierno en
Lula Pues el gobierno que viene
no solo Lula pero los partidos que que
han llevado a su Victoria es que al
mismo tiempo que tienes que implementar
políticas sociales o sea necesita
fortalecer el recurso público y utilizar
el recurso público para dirigir a esas
políticas sociales dado el grado de de
la pérdida de poder de compra de nuestro
salario mínimo
el aumento de más de 23% de la población
inseguridad alimentaria entonces creo
que ahí hay un hay necesitamos recursos
para para para para poder dirigir a las
políticas sociales pero al mismo tiempo
estamos viviendo de lo que es la
pospandemia y pues de algunas decisiones
del gobierno bucenario en términos de
por ejemplo use Lula prometido que ella
aumentara la bolsa familia que es un
programa muy importante en términos de
transferencia de renta a
familias muy pobres en Brasil y eso para
aumentar necesita una buena plata
entonces hay un dilema porque no es que
cómo es que el estado va a lograr
pues tener a esas gentes necesarias en
términos y además negociar con con un
congreso bastante
dividido pues más al centro al centro
derecha y también importante destacar
Pues el tema de cómo se compone los las
gobernaciones Lula va a gobernar muy
dividido en términos de 14 gobernadores
de oposición y 11 gobernadores o
entonces va a ser también un país
también muy dividido de de nordeste de
norte a su en términos de cuál Cómo se
va a dar esa también transferencia o
cómo se va a esas negociaciones ese
diálogos regionales a nivel nacional